[Music]
but
you
there is only one way this pandemic is
going to
but this is going to require first focus
build a cohesive global response signs
solutions and solidarity I thank you
thank you dr. Ted Rose I will now open
the floor to questions but would first
like to remind you we are translating
this is simultaneously in the six UN
languages so you can ask your question
in any of those plus you can ask in
Portuguese you may listen in Hindi for
Arabic you will need to go to Japanese
to the Korean button under the quirky
zoom system for right we have a lot of
people on the line my apologies I don't
think we'll get to everyone but we'll do
our best to get all your questions the
first reporter I have with a question is
Sarah Nui from The Telegraph United
Kingdom Sarah please unmute yourself and
go ahead hi there thank you so much for
taking my question and it's about the
WHI mission it's in China
just a quick one how long are the
experts there for but also it's been
reported in some press this morning that
the team is not planning to visit the
Wuhan institute of neurology I just
wondered if you could expand a little
bit on what their what they're doing
there and whether you've ruled out any
potential that the virus doesn't have
links to the lab thank you very much I
can speak to this Marie will maybe fill
in more detail I think I've outlined
this last week this is a preliminary
advance team that's there to work with
Chinese scientists and others to lay out
what the the main questions or what the
approach of what the studies that are
going to be needed by a much larger
international team that will work in
collaboration with Chinese colleagues
over the coming weeks and months I think
it's important to be clear on the
expectations for this preliminary
mission is true of our best scientists
joining our country team but joining
with Chinese colleagues to lay out that
we don't expect to be at this point
carrying out direct field investigations
this is not the objective of this for
the very preliminary mission this is to
understand what has been discovered
already what has been studied already
but the data that's available and then
from that lay out what further studies
need to be carried out and what
international experts would be useful in
engaging with and partnering with
Chinese colleagues in order to to do
that the length of the mission will be
determined by the by the the demands and
getting to that point but it's also
important to note that our two
colleagues are actually in quarantine at
the moment which is standard operating
procedure from from the Chinese side and
as such are already working with NAC
colleagues National Health Commission
and Ministry of Science colleagues in a
remote way being supported by our
country office so the team already
working but working remotely because
they were in quarantine and we will keep
you updated on progress with the
preparations for the international
mission and preparations for for that
and who will will travel and will be
part of that mission in due course may
wish to just lay out some of the issues
and complexities and studies Thanks yes
I mean like this a lot of what it starts
with is listening and learning you know
from our national counterparts I've
personally been on several missions for
whu-oh related to different emerging
infections and if I just think back to
MERS for example it took us more than a
year to identify the intermediate hosts
which are the dromedary camels but on
these types of missions what what we do
is we listen we learn we understand what
has been done so far so that we can work
with counterparts and with international
partners to lay out what needs to be
done in terms of what studies need to be
done at the animal human interface
usually what we would like to do is is
have a better understanding of the
initial cases that were reported what
what were the types of activities that
were done and then outline studies that
need to be carried out and those studies
take time but before you can design
studies that need to be carried forward
you need to understand what has been
done already and so this team will be
meeting with counterparts in China with
different ministries likely with
different academics and scientists to
really determine what has been done to
lay out the plan going forward and to
plan that larger mission
thank you very much doctors ryan and
doctors and kick off the next question
comes from
and yes Potrero from a jones
france-presse and yes please unmute
yourself and go ahead very well please
go ahead and yes okay thank you I would
like to ask you maybe I can ask you in
French with it okay so faster issues
with the savoir c'mon Loomis are you
until you love me a doctor it was a
really lousy Dominican Republik
observationally
a Sipapu messy yeah thank you thank you
for that question
I think we have said responded
previously on the same question and we
will respond maybe if there are
additional issues from our side when we
get the formal thank-you maybe just add
the teams here at WH o our teams around
the world 41 countries or six regional
offices ourselves are hundreds of
collaborating centers around the world
our partners in Goran our partners in
science all around the world we are
focused 100% controlling this pandemic
reducing at the DG said reducing
mortality suppressing transmission
building strong community responses to
this and an assisting governments with
strong coordination that is our liaison
focus right now we're also dealing with
many other situations around the world
we're dealing with the situation in
Syria which many of you seen is
deteriorating we're dealing with
situations in Yemen we're dealing with
other epidemics of Congo we're dealing
with plague in Natori in Congo we're
dealing with many many many emergencies
around the world that is our focus and
we trust that we will be able to
continue to work in scientific
collaboration but are wonderful
collaborators in the United States in
the years thank you dr. Ted Russ and dr.
Ryan the next question comes from
somebody who knows what it's like to
battle this virus firsthand the good
news is this is Cameron Kasimov who was
in hospital and has now recovered in is
at home
come on please go ahead I'm very glad to
hear you're well and please ask your
question can you hear me yes we can
please go ahead
hello yes I got clarity and surveys I
was in hospital it was very hard to the
base for me and I would like to take an
opportunity to learn there are other
Hema doctors from here from Riverdale
urging doctors protect others why would
you ask to you well antibiotics cannot
kill the virus completely from my
practice and even the person who
injected with the carnival's and because
is is it possible him to catch the virus
again a second time thank you so much we
will speak to the detail on this we
don't know yet whether it's possible
with this particular virus whether the
virus once you've had an infection and
recovered whether one can be infected
again we do know what other
coronaviruses that that is the case and
there is some data out there that may
suggest that immunity will wane over
time but that is not fully known at this
point we have more data on some recent
studies that are pointing in that
direction yes thank you for the question
and we're really happy to hear that
you're out of hospital and thank you for
sharing your experience we are learning
from a lot of people that they're
experienced with kovat is a challenging
one even if you have not the most severe
disease but even with mild disease we
know people are going through some
challenges so so well done on getting
out of the hospital into so many who
have who have been able to get out of
hospital so as Mike has said we do we
don't have a complete answer yet but we
do expect that people who are infected
with the SARS Coby - virus the virus
that causes Koba 19 they do mount some
level of an immune response and this is
measured through the antibody response
whether these are neutralizing
antibodies and we're learning quite a
lot about a t-cell response which are
very difficult studies to carry out what
we don't know is how how strong that
protection is and for how long that
protection will last
and so there are a number of studies
that are underway that are trying to
answer these questions there are some
initial studies out of three countries
in Europe that are looking at antibody
levels over time suggesting that they
may wane after a couple of months but
again that's early data and so we really
need more studies to better understand
this from our experience with MERS and
with SARS one the virus that spilled
over in in 2003 we know that people can
have an antibody response for maybe a
year or even longer but with the human
coronaviruses the ones that circulate
regularly it's much shorter than that so
it's an incomplete answer because we
don't have that answer yet but there are
many scientists that are currently
studying this that are trying to get
help help us better understand how long
that protection will last thank you very
much and I should tell everybody that
dr. soo Miah Swaminathan has joined us
joined us as well so my apologies for
not mentioning that earlier
so next question comes from Hong Kong
from Simone McCarthy from the South
China Morning Post Simone can you unmute
yourself and go ahead and ask your
question yes thank you so much can you
hear me very well please go ahead okay
great I I know that the the scoping
mission to China has already been
addressed once in this briefing so I'll
keep this quick but I was just curious
to know if there was any way to provide
further information about which experts
were on the ground in China going
through quarantine or perhaps why that
information isn't being shared thank you
we don't generally announced that the
names of our staff who go on on mission
in the field for no other reason and we
can certainly I can assure you is one of
the experts is a long-standing expert in
the animal human interface and has been
involved in multiple investigations in
the field of animal origin studies and
the other is very accomplished
epidemiologist who comes from from UK
academia and public health and is was
one of the leading well has led many
many epidemiologic missions but his
latest mission was in leading the
analytics cell in the field and the
Ebola response in North so both have
direct and recent experience in dealing
with complex epidemiologic
investigations and animal human
investigations in the field and we wish
them luck and all the support they need
in order to prepare for the for a larger
mission
thank you dr. Ryan the next question
will come from Christine from ABC News
USA Christine please unmute yourself and
go ahead
chrystine theodoro ABC News I wanted to
ask a question about transmission among
children from the last notes I have the
w-h-o reported children seem to be less
affected experience mild disease and are
less likely to show clinical symptoms
you had previously said that children
are susceptible just as adults and can
transmit but from some of the household
transmitted transmission studies excuse
me you were looking at it was very rare
that a child infects an adult and you
were trying to better understand when
people are infectious how people are
infectious and how do you measure that
today we're seeing a report from chief
health officer in Victoria state
Australia warning that extensive testing
in the state revealed child the child
transmissions are quote more impaired
--nt than they first thought and in the
US as you know there's an intense debate
around that's on going around school
reopening so we wanted to ask if there's
updated guidance for the w-h-o on child
transmissions whether that be child the
child or child to adult thank you in
advance this is a very important
question and this is one that has been
on our radar from the beginning of
course and looking at transmission as
well as severity and so what you had
said about children tend to be less
affected in terms of being reported as
cases that is true representing between
one and three percent in some countries
up to five percent of the reported cases
qwh oh there are some seroprevalence
studies that are being conducted that
are looking at antibody response and
children and there are a few studies
that are coming out now again they're
not all peer-reviewed publications but
some of those are pre print and what
we're seeing from them is that children
do seem to be we need to break down what
children mean the youngest children
under 10 years old for example versus
children over 10 and it depends on how
the study broke down age some of them
range from 5 to 9 some of them range
from 10 to 14 but what we're seeing is
that children in the youngest age groups
have a lower SERO prevalence and those
that are above 10 seem to have a similar
ceará prevalence to those that are among
older young adults and and above 20
years old which means that they can be
infected which we've said from the
beginning what they
the older children but again there's a
lot that we don't know about
transmission among children with regards
to schools and advice on schools w-h-o
has issued guidance on the safe running
of schools and making sure that certain
measures are in place we've also issued
guidance on when schools considerations
of when schools can reopen and that
takes into account a lot of different
factors that decision makers need to
take whether it relates to the
transmission that is occurring in the
local area or the catchment area of the
schools the type of school structure it
has the ability for the school to have
these implement to be able to implement
the measures like physical distancing
hand-washing etc and so there's a number
of considerations that need to take
place but as you highlighted children do
seem to be less affected but they can be
mild disease but in some situations they
can have severe disease and we have seen
that have died
yes and thank you very I think we've
been around if we cast our minds back
over the last couple of months we've had
healthy debates and around everything
from long-term care facilities to
transmission in dormitories to
transmissions and airplanes to
transmission on public transport health
care settings the workplace and now
schools and three is absolutely correct
and that we don't fully understand the
full contribution of children to the
overall epidemic the fact remains that
when community transmission exists and
when community transmission is intense
children will be exposed to that virus
and children will be part of the
transmission cycle they will be exposed
some will be infected and they may
infect others but we don't fully
understand is the impact on those
children in the long term we know in the
short term they tend to have milder
infections we don't know they impact in
the long term and we don't know to what
extent they pass that infection on and
infect others but we do know that that
can happen
so when we look at that and we can have
the same issues when it comes to the
workplace when we talk about employees
and the workplace and we talk about
long-term care facilities and health
workers and the facilities and older
people and visitors and to what extent
do visitors bring the disease in or to
what extent to help workers participate
in transmission and all of this is in
the setting of what's happening in the
community and in communities where
transmission has been effectively
suppressed where countries have been
successful in driving down transmission
of the disease across the board then you
reach a point where everything is safer
the problem we have in some countries
right now is that it's very difficult to
determine the safety of any environment
because there is just so much
transmission going on that all potential
environments in which people mix are
essentially problematic and that's a
problem we've all paid a heavy price
countries around the world have gone
into very serious movement restrictions
stay at home orders in order to suppress
the virus transmission and as
have opened up in some countries the
suppression of the virus has been kept
in place countries have opened up
carefully sequentially in the stepwise
fashion and have strengthened their
public health architecture and a
strengthened their capacity to
investigate clusters and suppress the
disease and in some cases implement
sub-national or targeted measures at
movement restriction or stay at home
orders and in that case schools are part
of that so yes there is an issue around
how much and to what extent children
participate in transmission there are
real issues around how schools can be
reopened safely but the best and safest
way to reopen schools is in the context
of low community transmission that has
been effectively suppressed by a
broad-based comprehensive strategy we
can't move from let's deal with the
schools and then we all deal with that
for a week or two and then let's deal
with the workplace or then let's deal
with infection and hospitals or
long-term care facilities this is
playing whack-a-mole we have got to
focus on a comprehensive long-term
strategy that focuses on everything at
one time we've got a chew gum and walk
at the same time and we keep and pulling
ourselves down various rabbit holes
schools are a hugely important part of
this they're a hugely important part of
our social educational architecture
the baseline of our civilization and but
we can't turn schools into yet another
political football in this game it's
it's not fair on our children so we have
to look at this carefully in the light
of the transmission in any given country
or any given setting and we have to make
decisions that are based on the best
interests of our children be it their
educational or their health interest and
that must be based on data that must be
based on understanding the risks in the
specific setting in which schools are
what is the community transmission and
what are those risks my fear and this is
that we we create these political
footballs that get kicked around the
place and it's it's it's for me we need
to get back to what the Director General
has just spoken about comprehensive
strategies sustained commitment to
broad-based virus suppression
we suppress the virus in our society in
our communities then our school schools
can open safely and there
you
so I would advise us all to look
every at schools we will continue to I
think we have a technical advisory group
meeting coming up Maria I want to speak
to that we're bringing experts together
from all over the world once more to
look at how we manage and Oakland
schools in a safe and effective way but
please that does not turn this into yet
another political football only add that
we have a that's been pulled together to
advise on us on educational institutions
specifically around how we do this
safely and it's a it's a global
collaboration there's there's a large
number of scientists that are helping to
advise us on this we have our second
meeting this week and is that is
something that we have specifically
pulled together for this because it is
such a complex issue and it is such an
important issue for all of us
thank you very much doctors Ryan and
doctors van Kerr calls our next question
comes from Catalan from NASA Ray Romero
from the Catalan News Agency NASA Sarah
please unmute yourself and go ahead very
well please go ahead so thank you very
much for taking my question I'll ask in
the Spanish if I may switch to commerce
and detect I'll Novus protests a new
operation plan españa y queria saber si
les preocupa Nestor no temperature
control chain otro scipios del mundo y
creo en su recommend a Sione's cuando se
detect and Brodie's locale 'is it
recommend our media's the convenient oh
what's the ruckus so thank you for the
question I think this is exactly what
the Director General was speaking to
today
and we spoke at our last press
conference about this and that in in
many countries that have been able to
suppress transmission there is always
the possibility of resurgence and what
is really important is that the
countries that have used this time and
have have spent the time to build this
public health infrastructure the
workforce in place the surveillance in
place the strategies in place to act
fast when there is an upsurge in cases
whether it's a small cluster or well
with
it's something that has an outbreak that
has started the the opportunity is to
act fast and to apply the same
comprehensive approach in forming your
your public saying where this virus is
what are we doing to suppress it what
role you can play as an individual role
we are playing as as leaders to be able
to bring these outbreaks under control
and I think that if the ability if the
infrastructure is in place if that
workforce is in place to find cases test
cases isolate cases carry out contact
tracing quarantine in contacts and
putting in place perhaps some
restrictive measures in a localized area
so not go into the full on nationwide
lockdown but to really apply measures at
the lowest administrator level as
possible to help support the outbreak
response that is something that we see
going forward where that can be done in
a data-driven way so there are
opportunities to suppress these
outbreaks these resurgence in these
pockets of activity very very quickly
and we're seeing a number of countries
really be successful in doing that very
quickly but it takes a surveillance
system in place to rapidly identify the
cases so that you know when you need and
where you need to act fast thank you
very much dr. van care cuff the next
question comes from China from yeah Li
from Xinhua News Agency please go and
meet yourself and please go ahead okay
thank you for taking my question can you
hear me very well please go ahead okay
good afternoon
I have a question about the origin of
the virus we noticed that last week no
the last week before last week Spanish
researchers tested chrono virus in
wasted water sample of March last year
after the ratio actors announced the
similar foundings
so based on these findings and Oxford
expert on pointed out that the chrono
virus may have been lying dormant across
the world until emerging under variable
conditions
so rather than originally in China
so I know we have asked such kind of
questions before but I won't I wonder
was the new learning or understanding
about tableau show on this issue of
wasted water thank you I certainly
surveillance of waste water is a really
good way of looking sometimes at the
long term epidemiology of any disease we
use surveys of wastewater for example to
track poliovirus around the world and
it's a very effective way of knowing
where am i rosy them up circulating
strains are certainly seen the same for
colouring of the diseases so they the
the environmental surveillance in
general is a very very useful way to
supplement human surveillance when it
comes to the understanding of disease
and we congratulate our scientific
colleagues for for using those methods
and innovations to look at the potential
this disease was was present earlier and
may have been previously suspected but
when it comes to investigating human
disease and the director-general spoken
of this many times you you you need to
go to the epicenter and work from there
we're very very clear the universe human
cases of this disease were picked up in
rust clusters of disease in China and
and then subsequently they spread from
there and that is where the starting
point lies for a full understanding of
the origins of this virus in the animal
kingdom and the animal source or the
intermediate hosts have not been
determined we assume the primary host is
a bath certainly that's also to be fully
determined but that is they the source
of the human cases or the first evidence
of human cases the question remains then
what was the what were the incidents or
incident that allowed the transfer of
that disease from animals to humans
where did that occur and that can occur
in the area in which the first human
cases are noticed or can occur far away
from there we've certainly seen an Ebola
and other this
is that the first human cases can be
unnoticed and then by the time you pick
the disease up it's already somewhere
else and that's been very often the case
in Ebola the first cases that are
noticed are in health workers well we
don't assume that the bats came and bit
health workers what usually is the case
is that there's a trail of cases going
back over some time and at some point
historically there was a transfer of
disease from the animals to humans so it
is a detective story in that regard and
you have to go where the data and the
science leads we keep saying we have to
follow the science and when it comes to
understanding the origins of disease you
have to follow the science too and it's
really really really important that's
ultimately and I'm sure our Chinese
colleagues are doing this already there
are tremendous capacities for disease
investigation and scientific
understanding that we start where the
disease began in humans or where the
first cases of disease are currently
humans and we work from there and we
keep an open mind and it's really
important that we keep an open mind
which you can't close your mind based on
one or two other findings that's where
that becomes a distraction and again you
end up being led down the different
alleyways that that are not helpful the
data and the evidence should lead where
it leads and this investigation and
understanding of how the disease
transmitted and where and by what animal
did this disease breach the barrier to
humans needs to be understood it's
extremely important that it is
understood and that investigation and
that scientific understanding should
start at where the first clusters of
human cases were detected that's in
China thank you thank you
so I have another commitment so I will
leave you with my colleagues my Maria
and Sonia and hope next session thank
you
yes so just just to supplement what mike
has said it's it's it is as he said we
listened and we learned we see what
investigations and studies are underway
we look what surveillance has happened
and we follow the science and so it is a
bit of detective work in that sense
where you're you're following the clues
and there is quite some work to be done
I mean if you think about the
identification of SARS the first SARS
virus it took it took over a year if you
look at MERS it took years if you look
at MERS that took us over a year so it
does take some time so I think we need
to manage the expectations about finding
the the intermediate host and how that
takes place
but I think what is important is that
there is this global collaboration
there's a whole network of scientists
that exists globally including the
scientists from China across the u.s.
across Europe across many different
countries all continents that always
look for these emerging pathogens and so
there's a large amount of work that's
underway we will follow the science we
are open to following that and I think
we are all committed to find the
intermediate host because of its public
health importance knowing what the
intermediate host is will help us to
prevent this from happening again thank
you very much doctor doctors Ryan and
dr. van karakov the next question comes
from Nairobi from Sarah jiving from DivX
Sarah could you kindly unmute yourself
and please go ahead thanks for taking my
question is the incubation period in the
timeframe in which a test result would
return positive the same would someone
need to wait the 14 days after exposure
to feel comfortable and a test result is
accurate and is the incubation time
frame still believed to be a maximum of
14 days or could it be longer so I can I
can start with that that's quite a few
questions in one actually so well done
to you so yeah so the incubation period
is is the point of time at where
somebody is exposed to the point of time
where they develop those develop
symptoms and it's believed to be between
1 and 14 days there are always
exceptions
we should say that there's always
exceptions but the majority the average
is between five and six days
so most people will develop symptoms
within five to six days your question
about the testing is is a good one
because we often get questions in terms
of our testing strategy of when is the
most appropriate time to test someone so
what we do within our case definitions
and our recommendations is to test
somebody when they develop symptoms
however saying that we do we also
recommend contact tracing so people who
are contacts go into quarantine which
means they're essentially removed from
from other people so that they can't
pass the virus on and some of those
contacts are tested they are tested when
they develop symptoms but some of those
individuals are tested when they don't
have symptoms which is why we're seeing
some asymptomatic cases being detected
if that testing is going to be done it
should be done before that 14 days is up
but it does depend on a lot of
characteristics of what type of test is
done what sample is collected whether
it's an upper-respiratory sample or
lower respiratory simple so there are a
lot of different factors that are that
are in play when it comes to when is the
most appropriate time to take a sample
from an individual just to boil I mean
the there's some excellent publications
out there around issues like this and
around broader issues but there is a
very good publication and in JAMA this
week which is a review of all of the key
parameters around the disease like
transmission and incubation and and
prognosis and so many other factors the
epidemiology and if there is probably
one it may be a little complex
scientifically impacts but for
journalists out there who really want to
get an overview of much of what we know
right now globally around the disease
versing a very good paper this week in
JAMA which kind of goes across the whole
range of what we know about this disease
because I think we said it here last
week we're all in a deluge a tsunami of
scientific publications and sometimes
when scientific colleagues synthesize
that into something a bit more
manageable it makes it makes things much
easier so I just point you to
publications like that where you can
pick up a lot of information regarding
what we know in a more synthetic fashion
very very helpful indeed
Thank You dr. Ryan and dr. Don Keiko now
okay great so our next question comes is
for
actually I think yeah I'm sure you can
answer it as well dr. Childress said the
America's remainder episode pandemic and
I'm just
just wandering looking at the I mean
really big increase in cases that we
have seen particularly of this last
weekend on a public-health
basis what's gone wrong and what needs
to be done as a matter of urgency if we
look at the Americas as a whole
I think well and the DG alluded to this
in many circumstances countries made
some progress in suppressing
transmission but certainly the reopening
in those countries have led to more
intense transmission and now a number of
countries face a scenario in which
there's increasing and sometimes
exponential transmission in a very
difficult situation to face and not
necessarily with the option to impose
these so-called lock downs again because
of the economic damage and the community
acceptance of those but as etc said
there is no situation which cannot be
faced and I think this is the issue is
to turn and face the fire turn and face
the problem and accept that it's going
to take time it's going to require a
huge commitment on the part of
government and individuals in a number
of countries to turn this around and
it's not just government it's
individuals the choices we make I think
I spoke about that last week there are
choices that we all make that can either
increase or decrease the risk of
transmission but there are choices that
governments make that can either
increase or decrease the risk of
transmission we need to re-establish
trust communication and strong
government led strategies that can turn
this around some of that may require
limited or geographically focused
lockdowns that's suppressed transmission
in specific areas where transmission is
frankly out of control but that is not
the case in all places all countries in
the Americas have areas and their
countries in which transmission is at a
reasonably low level but some areas
in almost all countries have areas of
intense transmission and in those
situations absolute individual and
community adherence the social
distancing hygiene the wearing of mass
when appropriate all of those different
things if everybody does that then we
will suppress transmission avoiding
crowded places but if people continue to
frequent crowded places without taking
the necessary precautions of people
aren't practicing physical distancing if
people aren't practicing hygiene if
people aren't wearing masks in the
proper settings then the disease will
continue to transmit at the same time
governments have to support communities
in that and governments have to be again
Ted Roth spoke to it very clearly we
need to be absolutely clear and
consistent in our messaging to our
citizens and it's got to be easy for
citizens to comply it's got to be met
facilitators and it's got to be
supported so and within all of that as
we get control back of the disease and I
can't say this strongly enough the
countries that have put in place strong
Public Health surveillance architecture
while they've been dealing with their
lockdowns are now emerging from those
lock tones in a stepwise fashion and
they're replacing lockdowns with strong
public health capacity to detect to test
to quarantine and treat cases and
countries that have taken that path are
having relative success in continuing to
suppress the virus but as I've said here
before we need to learn to live with
this virus expecting that we will
eradicate or eliminate this virus in the
coming months is is not realistic and
also believing that magically we will
get a perfect vaccine that everyone will
have access to is also not realistic the
history of vaccines are that we we can
and will develop a vaccine the question
mark is how effective will that vaccine
be and more importantly a more
worryingly who will get that vaccine and
will that distribution be fair and
equitable but as terrorists are said
there are things we can do now there are
tools we have at our disposal now if we
apply them and if we apply them
systematically and if communities and
individuals buy into that
trust that their behavior will be
supported by government and we can work
together collectively to drive down and
suppress transmission the positive news
in this is that in many countries death
rates have fallen and we are getting
better at treating cases we're getting
better at diagnosing cases early and we
need to continue that we need to
suppress mortality suppress transmission
we need to support communities we need
clear and strong government leadership
and that doesn't matter where you work
but that's all the more important in
countries that are now suffering a very
very exponential transmission which is
very very worried thanks Mike I want to
speak to the individual so as Mike I
said it it's it's not only about
leadership it's about individuals and
what individuals do and and everyone
everyone on the planet needs to know
what role they have to play and to be
informed about what this virus is where
this virus is circulating especially in
the areas where you live the areas where
you work the areas that you want to
travel in all of this is important
there's so much that you can do yourself
to protect yourself from getting
infected and to prevent yourself from
passing the virus on just unto others
and please make good choices I know that
there are a lot of things that we want
to be doing right now but there aren't
necessarily a lot of things that we need
to be doing right now there are many
people many people essential workers who
cannot stay at home there are many
people who are caring for patients and
hospitals who cannot stay at home and if
you can and if you can help and if you
are asked to please stay home you can
practice physical distancing from others
you can avoid crowded places you
couldn't avoid places that have enclosed
settings that have poor ventilation you
can clean your hands you can practice
respiratory etiquette you can wear a
mask if you cannot do physical
distancing there are so many things that
you could be doing talking to your
children explaining to them the risks
everyone has a role to play and and this
is far from over
so we all have to play our part thank
you very much
doctors Ryan and Van kickoff we have
time for one more question and he's been
waiting for a long time and so he can
still ask Kristen it's Jamie from
Associated Press Jamie Keaton Jamie
please go ahead as a que Margaret my
question was for dr. Ted Rose Thanks
okay well dr. Ryan's got an update on
Ebola because last week we promised that
we would give those the updated
situation so dr. Ryan please go ahead
contracts as of the the 12th of July
we've had 48 confirmed cases and three
probable cases reported from Ecuador
problems in North Western DRC 17 deaths
of confirmed cases and the tree three
deaths of the three probable cases
eleven survivors we've had 21 effective
health areas in six health sore neck
guitar and that does well the numbers
are low that does represent a broad
geographic extent of the virus and that
is of a concern well the numbers are
quite low in each el sol any one of
those individual cases can result in an
amplification of disease in terms of the
areas that are affected there are five
zones that we've had cases in the last
21 days and most of the zones in fact
have had a case in the last 7 to 10 days
so we're still within that incubation
period for another wave of cases in in
the in the zones of the coral in balumbo
in boco in the tombe and man back itself
in terms of the age and sex distribution
males predominate amongst the cases
females represent 43 percent of cases
and children less than 18 6% of cases in
terms of the epidemiologic links at the
beginning of the outbreak
as is normal and many of Ola outbreaks
it's difficult to make the association
between cases because they sometimes
there are difficult exposure histories
and particularly when people have
already died but at presence the with
the documented at the beginning of the
outbreak and the first week 75% of cases
had no documented epidemiologic link
from the 29th of June to the 5th of July
33% had no documented link but all cases
in the last week of a document of epi
links to other cases that's good news
the the the the difficult part of that
is that the proportion of people who are
registered and followed as contacts is
is less than half and that means that
you know half of cases are not being
actively followed as context when
they're diagnosed and again while the
numbers of those are very very small
that is is not a good parameter and
again in terms of that's a community
level where we've seen that's in the
community again they all represents
opportunities for disease transmission
at the moment as of July the 11th we're
tracking 5580 contacts across very very
large and difficult geographic zone with
extreme logistics we've managed on a
daily basis to follow 4970 7 or 89%
nearly 90% of those contacts are
followed on a daily basis which is good
performance in the context of the the
extreme logistics in the area but it
also means that 10% of contacts are not
followed and that in itself is a concern
the in terms of community alerts we're
investigating or detecting about between
five and six hundred alerts at community
level every day of them 25 percent are
validated the suspect cases and and then
then those individuals are tested there
are still challenges in
testing we've very recently established
testing capacity in Bakura which is to
the south so we now have testing
capacities and in all of the effective
health zones and we have clinically
capacity with partners and all of the
affected households
you
same context as North kiru we don't have
the same necessarily the same security
issues but we do have very very big
logistics and distance and living
conditions
conditions were for staff and the
condition of the roads etc we've
vaccinated thousands of people with our
vaccination teams and we're very lucky
to have that
and those vaccination teams in place and
equally so therapeutics are in the field
and now being actively used to treat
cases the r0 for the last two weeks of
June was 1.7 which means technically
each case is generating more than one
other case so this is still an active
very active outbreak and I would say it
is still a great concern the ecuador
province is on on the river congo
it is also across the river from two
other countries it is a very very large
geographic area communities are linked
and people do travel long distances so
there are a number of features of this
epidemic that are of concern very much
thank the government of congo for its
leadership the partners in the UN and
the NGO system for the support they're
providing but i would caution everyone
that while the numbers in this event are
low again it's in the era of COBIT it's
very important that we do not take our
eyes off these other emerging diseases
and we saw in north kibo in other
previous outbreaks of Ebola that these
can get out of control very easily we're
very focused on continuing to support
the government of Congo in in
eliminating Ebola once more in this
situation thank you thank you very much
dr. Ryan and with that I'll close this
press conference for today we'll send
the audio file as usual to the globalist
and the next press conference will be on
Friday
that's Friday the end of this week